i'm throwing this together really quick
because i'm seeing this show up not only
in like other people's postings about
the new doctor shrutigatwa but also uh
showing up in my own comments there
seems to be uh a belief that gatwa is
gay or openly gay uh we don't know if if
ghatwa is gay or any kind of queer
because he's not openly anything he is
very private and personal about his
sexuality and has never answered
questions about it straightforwardly now
again does that mean he isn't gay or is
it some form of queer no absolutely not
but he's not openly anything i think a
lot of people are making assumptions
based off the fact that the character he
played in sex education is gay which
no that's not an assumption anyone
should be leaping to i'm still super
excited for the casting the more i think
about it and the more i see of him in
interviews the more i'm like i really
want to see what he's gonna do but don't
praise this as the first casting of an
openly queer person as the doctor
because even if he is queer it's not
openly and we don't even know if he is